si la ciudad de que baa decidió decretar
un nuevo toque de queda un toque de
queda que entrará en vigor en la noche
de hoy y que se mantendrá en vigor hasta
el jueves en la mañana la decisión llega
después de los intensos bombardeos que
esta ciudad asediada por el ejército
ruso ha sufriendo en los últimos días
bombardeos que han afectado barrio por
barrio y que también han golpeado a
edificios de zonas residenciales y en
tanto los primeros ministros de polonia
eslovenia república checa han viajado a
tierra para expresar la soledad del
consejo de europa en este contexto
continúa la guerra en ucrania las
sirenas antiaéreas se han vuelto a
disparar también en la ciudad portuaria
de odense y también en libia donde nos
encontramos donde también hemos oído a
drones sobrevolar en los suburbios en
esta zona del oeste del país que tiene
mantiene una frontera con polonia un
país miembro de la unión europea y
también de la organización del tratado
del atlántico norte